you know you speak about cancer
prevention we all break to sigh of
relief when you said no more cancer is I
haven't really said that you know what I
said was it haven't detected any cancer
but sometimes the cancer spots including
in my brain which is one millimeter
which is a tiny little thing and so I'm
still taking treatments regularly and
I'll continue that until the doctors
tell me
what would you say to those other people
you're such an inspiration for all those
fighting cancer what would you say to
them and how is Rosalind and her support
helped you very well her supporters help
me you know for the last sixty nine
years after they married and everything
I've ever tried and of course when I was
ill I thought I was you know my day any
time that she was there for me and she
agreed with the info and was excited
with me when I found out that my
metabolism responded well to the
treatment we didn't know ahead of time
before them would not but uh but i have
my own immune system seems to be
responding you're fit you look fit as a
fiddle well as soon as I used to be busy
like 91 years old now